man that that quote that dana
said had me howling this is about the
logan paul fight
yeah what did he say he's talking about
mayweather and
i dropped a lot of fighting and car
related stuff in the threat i'm sorry
but it was just too good
dana said when people ask me well let me
try to do my best dana white impression
you know when people ask me
what's the state of boxing right now
that's where it's at
didn't that kid get beat up by the
[ __ ] video kid came from england
and now he's going to fight floyd
mayweather
didn't that kid get beat up by the
[ __ ] video game kid oh my god
that's so that's so brutal whenever
someone
you know i feel like he has he has a way
fighters
and people that are involved with
fighting have a way
of packaging of being very poignant when
it comes to like insulting someone
like ksi like the amount of [ __ ] that
he's done you know what i'm saying
no matter what you think of him you
can't not respect him for all the [ __ ]
that he's done
no but just to cl just to classify him
in in three words as that video game
it's [ __ ] brutal that f the [ __ ]
video game
kid
[Laughter]
[ __ ] video game kid
it's so goddamn funny dude
[Laughter]
that kid get beat up by the [ __ ]
video game kid from england
jesus christ man you know
never mind all the fighting and [ __ ] i
think
it's uh i i love the clip of logan
act there's it's him react he filmed the
clip of himself
reacting to
the fight announcement yeah i saw that
and i just got to commend him if
if that wasn't acting you know
just the it it it looked as though he
was doing a scene
you know i'm about to fight one of the
biggest fighters of all time my god
oh like he's really pretending yeah i
mean how did he not know
like that reacting to floyd's instagram
post
that and
what are you guys really gonna do in
there it doesn't it doesn't make sense
to me i don't know i it just it just
doesn't make sense like
how can you be excited for that how it
just doesn't make sense
it's like why he i watched an interview
with him and he was like floyd was like
i don't well bill gates is still making
money off microsoft
and that was his specialty you know
that's what he he
he built that legacy and everything and
then and
you know so such and such is still
making money off this technology that he
invented
why can't i do exhibition matches and
make a [ __ ] ton of money forever
and be like the guy that does exhibition
matches oh
it's like it's it's just i mean i i mean
not
if you want to make [ __ ] millions and
millions of dollars for sure go for it
but
it will tarnish your legacy a little bit
it has to it has to you're an athlete
you're not a
you know it's not the same thing as as
inventing or building a company or
something like that it's like you you
you were extremely successful off your
like athletic prowess which
everyone knows only lasts like 10 years
max you know
i feel that the pandemic has
accelerated this kind of desperation and
entertainment
yeah maybe yeah no this is something
floyd
may would have only entertained and
joked about
but the fact that you know
maybe this isn't specific to floyd and i
don't really know what floyd would have
done outside of boxing but
maybe there were more things he could
have gotten into if the world was
kind of normal but because it's not i
feel that
that's what's making these people
consider these weird mashups with
youtubers and stuff because they
they need to get they need to get paid
somehow yeah so
i don't know that whole paper that whole
pay-per-view structure is such a money
grab the whole thing is just
it's a scam it's a scam i mean
it yeah it i i don't know
so was wwe though and people still watch
that like
even if it's scripted and it's whatever
it's still gonna be a show
and people watch it and so that's
entertainment and that's what floyd said
he's like it's just entertainment
which i agree with but i just think they
got so [ __ ] lucky like
finding this weird niche within an
already somewhat niche sport yeah that
for some reason everyone wants to watch
like it's
[ __ ] bizarre how do the depauls do
this how the [ __ ]
if you told me two years ago that logan
paul will be fighting floyd mayweather
dude you know what's so funny is i
looked at jake paul's youtube channel
and you go one year back just one year
he's got all those goofy thumbnails with
him posing with that little kid
remember there's that short period where
he was pimping out that kid for views
and i laughed and i put that thumbnail
next to
his latest music video thumbnail and i
was like this is how quickly
people forget it was a year ago this
dude is
like hoeing out a seven-year-old i have
never seen
whatever this little baby's name is i've
never seen him cry like this
you know no he got he got in trouble
with school and
he's upset and now he's like i got a fbi
charge
what the [ __ ] is going on here
how did he convince all these people
that he's cool i
man i don't know it just goes to show
like
i something about those two kids
like i don't know they they're just
their desire to like open as many doors
as possible until they find the way to
the gold
is is like unbreakable and so
i mean i hate to like i'm not saying
let's all take a page out of their books
i'm just saying like it just goes to
show like
you just keep trying [ __ ] and throw [ __ ]
at the wall and then
eventually you find some [ __ ] like this
where now you're [ __ ] now he's
fighting the best fighter in the world
and it's like
what how well the thing that the paws
understand is that this is a unique time
where two guys like them can do [ __ ]
like this
you know they couldn't do they do you
think they understand that or you think
they just got lucky but just
like i said just trust [ __ ] no i think
they understand it like they do
something it gets views
they can wrap their head around okay if
i do this again it's gonna get more they
they're not that dumb
you know no no yeah i'm i'm saying
no that's what i'm saying is you start
out
what was their first fight um
it was the whole you know logan versus
ksi
and then yeah jake paul yeah yeah so
they started with that
which had headgear and all and
everything and it wasn't a pro fight and
that was
nowhere near the level that this is at
now
yeah and that wasn't during a pandemic
they were just like all right let's just
we want to fight i bet you people will
buy tickets to this and they try it
and then yeah you then they make like
strategic decisions based on that but
yeah well i think that they they sold
so many pay-per-views that weekend that
they realized oh okay we have something
here with boxing you know we don't
that's their version of stand-up you
know that's their version of doing a
live like a live tour
so they uh and obviously that money's
crazy so they're gonna say yeah let's
let's do it again so they know how to
it is that whole wrestling aspect where
they're selling it and they're talking
[ __ ] they're making videos about each
other it's definitely that wwe
sort of model right just preying on
the the drama and all that yeah they
they get that
for sure i think unintentionally
they built up such a history of
data that they had enough to convince
all these cronies these old people
hey man you wanna you wanna get paid
look at what we did
we've only done two fights look how much
money we've made off of two fights and
all these boxing promoters go
huh how'd you do that sean
yeah say well if you sign the line for
this amount of money we'll bring that to
you
they didn't know that they were going to
do that but that's the position they're
in yeah
so i think and and i think the paul's
have that
um they have that thing that
they're easy to understand and they're
easy to hate and that's what keeps them
easy to talk about yeah i don't know
this is our second episode about them in
a week i know well
well how can you not talk about it
that's that's the [ __ ]
that's why that's why i don't get it man
it [ __ ]
confuses me oh
it i mean i saw a dude do a video
and i i feel bad that not remembering
his name
i think if you just search the terms
like jake paul late stage capitalism or
something
he just kind of you know he just kind of
talks about how a guy like jake paul
uh of course someone like this was going
to exist you know
just there's the natural sort of
obsession and interest and
uh having money and all that that's i
now more than ever that is like super
pronounced so
two guys like them just they understood
that they milked that [ __ ] to the wheels
fall off
so you know i don't know they're going
to dance around the rain they're going
to make millions of dollars and then
we'll see
you know everyone's going to keep paying
to watch them fight until one of them
gets
punked they should literally floyd and
logan should literally just dance around
the ring
oh that's what they're gonna do like
it's just entertainment man it's an
exhibition fight
like we just have to actually fight we
can just like yep yeah
okay they both were doing like
interpretive dance
that is my prediction man logan is gonna
be like i'm gonna kill him and this and
that they're gonna get in there and then
yeah that's basically what it's gonna be
they're gonna
lock up hands and slow dance
[Music]
the other thing too that's so funny is
and this is my armchair analysis and
sorry i'll just stop steamrolling the
[ __ ] in a second but
this whole you know what that logan and
them have done really well is selling
the idea that they have a puncher's
chance
like oh logan's bigger and if he just
[ __ ]
you know if he just he's a big dude and
if yeah
right yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude floyd has the most unique training
in that
his hands he like he he broke i think
his left hand like early in his career
and
he kind of realized that maybe relying
on punching
uh would not extend his career so he's
trained his whole career to be defensive
yeah blocking yeah you know getting out
the [ __ ] way
yeah there's not a single punch that
logan with
even you know just a year of boxing
training that floyd's gonna see
like logan it's gonna be in logan's eyes
and his elbow and his shoulder and
floyd's like eye's gonna hip there's the
one
and there's the there's the one two and
then yeah but but
what if what if dude here's no but
here's the thing
the line is one to 1750 right now for
for logan to win so
okay let's say let's say you put 100 we
put down 500 bucks on that okay
okay 500 bucks on that which i might do
honest i hate to say that i'm going to
bet on logan but
there was that little chance that maybe
he sneaks one through and floyd all of a
sudden
you know maybe floyd i don't know what
he like zones out for a second
it looks it wrong boom on the ground
we went nine hundred thousand dollars
yeah yeah
no definitely definitely
no definitely you put some money down
and and see what happens but
i is that um how do the boxing how's
boxing betting work anyways
is it i think it's like you have to bet
you know will someone win in this round
knockout no i think you can
i mean i think that you can bet on
anything that you want to bet on
yeah probably and where you go and but
that's just for uh knockout i'm pretty
sure
so ladies and gentlemen if there's any
way you wanted to stick it to the paul
brothers
throw a hundred bucks on logan winning
no that's not
is that is that sticking it to the paul
brothers not really but if you've ever
wanted a piece of their success now's
the time
now's the time now dirty would that
money feel afterwards
disgusting you know you're like signing
the [ __ ] check for your lambo and
you're like oh
i had to bet on that paul logan paul for
this scent he crashed
and now you're driving around that
lamborghini with a
with an air freshener of logan paul's
face
and you have your maverick t-shirt on
and you can't believe how you've arrived
here and you're
35 you're 35.
you can't believe it you started out
hating these guys on a random
comedy duo's podcast and now you're a
daily
upload consumer yeah of logan paul
that's the thing is that is that even
even if i refuse to watch it even if i
take that bet
i'm i'm falling for it i'm i'm exactly
everyone else that they're just preying
on right now with this
event yes you are
what are the odds that it's going to be
entertaining they said it's it's
supposed to be entertainment what are
the odds that's going to be
at all entertaining have you ever i mean
have you ever watched the floyd fight
yeah and i like i actually like watching
him fight
people fast and i mean yeah people call
him boring because he's defensive and
does
i know there's been debate about his
boxing style i you know i find it
interesting
as far as you know how how he approaches
boxing
you know you can't deny that he's one of
the greatest to ever do it but
i don't think because i don't know the
the where the like what weight they're
gonna fight at and all that so if
logan has to come down and wait and then
train at that weight and he's never
trained at that weight before
and you know his gas tank was good
against ksi but it wasn't
amazing so eight rounds with floyd
that's like
can you even bet that logan's gonna have
the conditioning to like really
be in round six like and be competitive
i don't know
so so you're saying maybe it will be
entertaining
maybe not see the thing is like i like
watching boxing i think it's
entertaining and i like watching floyd
fight
but you know and i liked watching the
undercards to
um to the tyson fight except for when
the jake
and nate once started the first you know
until the knockout it was not
entertaining at all
no if anything it made everyone in the
room angry they were like what the [ __ ]
are we watching this isn't
anything two guys hugging and not
knowing what they're doing
and then the knockout happened and then
it was like okay that was worth it right
but that's way less likely to happen in
this one unless it's
logan getting knocked out by i mean yeah
floyd might just
will probably do to logan what he did to
connor where he's gonna
you know he'll he'll he'll box how he
boxes he's gonna let logan try to beat
him up
and he's gonna know exactly how he's
gonna do it and then logan does three
rounds of that he's like i can't [ __ ]
hit this old man and then
that's when floyd comes out smiling and
he's like you ready to go to sleep and
then he's going to start touching him up
okay so maybe it will be who knows maybe
you know what i'm saying
mm-hmm they say it's supposed to be
entertainment but it just seems like a
weird
it doesn't seem like the chances of i
don't know maybe i'm wrong maybe we'll
see
we'll definitely see i guess we'll see
but we should stop talking about it
because